oh yeah good victory guys good victory
hey come on good game slap-ass hey
Garcia come on man get you some come on
let's get some slap-ass over here no why
why not I see no Rafi he's had enough
Rafi we've all had enough enough why
enough with the damn ass-slapping Rafi
gracias si yes I'm baseball player
that's what we do we in hit home runs it
slap-ass come on roughy that's not how
we all see baseball
everybody does it all the teams that
Batman and yo you slap ass Garcia like a
couple of dice the game can e mean who
knows how many times I slap bass or 427
times
okay time flies when you have a fine man
what a families come to these games Rafi
my soul is always asking me why I'm
letting this man touch my bus so many
times and you say 'slap-ass every time
every time okay hold on one second let's
go to the timeout
I found the Dominican Republic okay all
I know since I was a little kid is to
catch fly balls and to say 'slap-ass
everything this is the major leagues
rafi we are all permit American Republic
nobody here has ever heard anyone say
'slap-ass before Jew
quit playing man come on get your
slap-ass Rafi enough okay
[Music]
okay
you're right I know you're right about
it I have a problem okay I know that and
I decided to stop right now
but after i get that garcia slap-ass
come on I'm fine all right fine I get a
girl man can I talk to you for
oh no hey Rafi what's up huh
oh man I just talked to the manager man
he says he's gonna trade me man I mean
what the hell you know I got kids too
right here yeah but we all told you
always going to happen if you hey I
really could use that one slap-ass man
Rafi come on just one slap-ass
no just Wanda just for old times sake
you know give me back on my feet
I mean just one for the road man I could
really use it
good game
I gotta get home for my kids
oh gosh here man I suck you if you let
me slap your ass again bro
[Music]
[Music]
you